what's going on it's bill burr and it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna I'm just checking in on you this is
not an official podcast this is why I
just checked it on you on a Thursday
let's see how your [ __ ] workweek is
going and most times what you know the
deal I do it by myself I lay around I
shoot the [ __ ] I say things people hear
things they think that it's about them
and who is arisen in the White House who
the [ __ ] knows but every once in a while
I bring on a guest and when I do I don't
just bring on any guests I bring on some
of the most talented people out there
some of my great friends and today this
is no different I have the great Ben
Bailey from Cash Cab he's got a new
special he's got a bunch of short films
he's got a new websites got a bunch of
[ __ ] he wants to talk about Ben Bailey
what's up man how the [ __ ] are you I'm
good dude
good yeah you too now I have when was
the last time I saw you it wasn't last
November ah might have been where I've
seen you once since then but we had to
have some sort of festival yeah yeah
maybe out here but you're talking to
walking by to some social media tent
you're talking about a Madison Square
Garden no was last November was that a
year ago already yeah it was it was the
the no longer Toyota Comedy Festival
I'll release it done isn't just a New
York comes New York no yet do you have
how many years when we were in New York
I came to New York and like 95 right I
believe in yeah that's just a couple
years after me I started out here and
then went back there okay and we did
like what we did like maybe four or five
thousand shows together
yes I'm like that I literally sat down
one time and this is 15 years ago now or
maybe like 12 somewhere in there and I
try to sort of have you know add up some
idea of how many stand-up shows I had
done what do you think I came up with
10,000 yeah it was that was you know at
least 10 years ago probably more and you
count as shows every time you go on yeah
yeah he said I did anyway that's fair
because any time you go up god knows
what the [ __ ] happy yeah yeah it
doesn't matter if it's four or five
minutes yeah somebody can still there's
plenty time if you have something thrown
at you yeah I'm an awful you know
something I I remember I kept counting
until about like 26 into 30 maybe then I
just lost it but I remember I keep a
track of how many you
yeah I probably did too I don't even
remember but I probably did too I was
always jealous of people that did that
cuz I'm sort of like like I like I hate
stats and like trying to figure out what
people where people are socially but I
love them in sports because they're like
they're kind of fact as far as like how
many home runs you hit you know that
that's like a ladder too it gives you
some something to go up against yeah but
I don't buy in the [ __ ] like you
know oh and then when it's raining out
and will blow when you get to that [ __ ]
like I'm more into the how many yards
did this guy throw for how many do you
run and or whatever stuff like that
right not at specific situations they do
break it down a little too far you like
what yeah I could see the reason because
we have like 9 19 maybe 24 hours sports
networks plus the internet plus
[ __ ] like me and all that it the
whole thing it's just way too much
information and what I was trying to get
to was do you remember when the Toyota
Comedy Festival first came around yeah
was the funniest [ __ ] ever was just this
table would say that it was the festival
there was like nobody I ever met that
was connected with it they were just
hang a banner it was just a banner at
the regular clubs yeah it was all the
same regular performers there was no
industry and it just feel and I remember
st would leave on this weekend we have
the Toyota Comedy Festival and we have
Ben Bailey Bill Bergey was always a
banner it took us like we were all so
excited cuz we had nothing going on in
our careers yeah like I'm part of the
festival it took about three years
before somebody find just said you know
what what is this [ __ ] Leon's like
gayest of all this is every this is a
regular Wednesday right and somehow
though that morphed into an actual
festival or the New York Comedy Festival
right which is I think is you know
there's a lot of festivals you know out
there but like New York City you got to
have a big Comedy Festival you got it
yeah I think so I think it's great I was
actually I wasn't been a part of it
really but I'm supposed to be next to
you later groundwork for the first nine
years when it was yeah I understand yes
that's right I was a part of it for the
first nine and then they started booking
people and I missed the cut yeah [ __ ] I
don't know yeah you and me both I came
over the the New York underground comedy
first of all I don't think I was a part
of that I'm sure I submitted a VHS tape
to it the joke was that it was so
underground that
literally no one knew about it was it
sounded like surf reality it was the
same thing it was like it was like a
banner at a couple of clubs you know and
some guy some guy had a bunch of money
was i coming to have a festival you know
that's a great way in from LA and stuff
and these guys would come in they're
like you know we're here for the
festival and we're all like what what
are you talking about I'm sure we
greeted them warmly well the last time
well I guess sort of meandering my way
towards was that Toyota of Comedy
Festival then morphed into the New York
Comedy Festival right and that's what
that they MSG gig was last year and as I
mention as I mentioned to you guys you
know obviously that was a nerve-wracking
gig and I just you know I don't I can't
remember how the [ __ ] came but I pray
for doing the goddamn Comedy Jam or
whatever I was like right I've asked my
agent I was like hey wait we paid to
rent that thing all day right
considering 90% of the money is gonna go
right back to renting that giant [ __ ]
place I go yeah I said can I like rent a
drum kit first I was just gonna run a
drum kit and just jam with my you know
my music by myself typical comedian tour
I isolated but because of Josh Adam
eiders in the goddamn Comedy Jam the
people there like we're gonna be in town
so I rented all this gear and there was
this running thing with me and Ben word
for about eight years we were trying to
get together and play music you play
drums I played guitar we gonna get
together every [ __ ] time he'd come
out here to LA and it's like he's
running around he's got meetings he
couldn't [ __ ] make it and then I get
to New York and he you're out in Jersey
and that's just when you don't have a
[ __ ] car it's like oh my god I'm
gonna get on the path train do anybody
to come out gypsy cab so finally like
we're just like I come to town and we
were gonna jam and then that's when I
finally solidified it and I was gonna
drive out to your place so and you are
all excited cuz you've made it yeah yeah
do you know that I built and everything
I'm like aw we're finally gonna play in
it and he's all amped up tell me how
great his [ __ ] studio is and I was
like I don't know man I think I got a
better place yeah you're like I got a
better place I'm like yeah what the [ __ ]
and I just said I didn't give you the
address I think I told you was MSG I
said well I finally I wrote back we're
like I was like it must be someplace
good yeah he's not just slamming my home
studio that I built without having seen
it he must have some MSG I'm like
monosodium glutamate yeah [ __ ]
Madison Square Garden man I knew when I
said I have a better place your next
text was gonna come back in all capitals
and doesn't take any [ __ ] from anybody
and he's actually big enough to beat the
[ __ ] I mean about 20 other people so
he's what the [ __ ] I totally insulted a
studio so what do you need a better
place yeah so we end up coming down and
as I mentioned before is that my phone
oh Jesus Christ bill can you feel it
just makes it real listen it makes
people feel like they're actually in the
studio witnessing how unprofessional
this is how many of them like jumped up
and looked around I know cuz I do have
in the floor race they're like oh oh no
that's that's the standard way hiding in
the closet and there's a serial killer
walking around you know there's a chance
when your phone rings he won't know what
shoe he'll think it's he'll think it's
his fault for a second maybe you can
drop all them look at it you [ __ ]
smother him with your PJs oh it's a
great scene in a film right there oh
there you go killer checks his own phone
he's like God yeah could you once in
your life be professional speaking of
playing music is I have like the hearing
damage that I have which is inevitable
if you play or you do this [ __ ] rate
of the hearing damage that I have is I
actually got my hearing check like I
still can hear everything but I have a
little bit of displacement as to where
it is like it'll be told right and I
start going to the left hit my life just
resting man just laughs at me yeah it's
from doing stand-up and like playing
music and yeah having headphones alt I
know Opie from my Opie and he says my
ears are shot because what happens is
your ears get tired you know you keep
turning up and turning up it's all about
the directional right guys do like four
hours a day and I try to be conscious of
it but like I [ __ ] my ears up in the
80s one of my ears I got that tinnitus
yeah
just rings it a real low-level or if I'm
really hung over it but I mean I don't
have like like to the Pete Townsend
level but uh
so anyways getting back to its so it
doesn't he had to quit I know right but
not from the music from racecar driving
she's like what was that what is from
yeah that's what they said it wasn't you
know he's it's been an ac/dc all these
years
like the loudest [ __ ] band but no
that's not why his ears are damages from
driving race cars one of my first times
I really [ __ ] my ears up as I saw them
on the was they hate secret or oh no I
saw him it mad I saw em at the Boston
Garden nice I think Cinderella opened no
no I saw him down in Providence was a
different tour I saw them a bunch of
time who made who Heatseeker all during
that whole period I used to go see him
and I didn't have earplugs and as loud
as that was the [ __ ] dude driving
home he had the [ __ ] thing turned all
the way up to [ __ ] 10 and I remember
just like sitting in the back just
taking it rather than ask him hey can
you turn that down you're making all but
no I I had like that German Irish just
like yeah don't complain don't complain
suffer in silence yes it'll it'll be
over soon like when you're in the back
of a car in the guys driving like a
[ __ ] maniac
and I'm like being polite yeah I'm like
I don't want to offend him by asking him
to slow down or whatever I'd rather just
risk my own death hey not that guy
trying to be that guy but I'd like to
live yeah I'd like to survive this ride
yeah don't be in a halo at the end of
this but anyway so we finally ended up
getting to play at Madison Square Garden
yes I think it was worth the [ __ ] way
it was worth it was our Chinese
Democracy dude I gotta tell you man I
wouldn't change a thing
you [ __ ] can play oh really play man
I was really a cute onus is crazy and I
got I got to show that to uh you know a
bunch of people when I got to do the
Tonight Show yeah I showed it to
question Fallon and stuff I think I
showed schweiz I showed it to and they
were just like wow Alice Q should have
given us you know Jimmy's all you should
have give mr. video we would have
Plato's just like all right dude it's
not that good I like that was so fun
dude it really was it really wasn't Josh
I was going off and surreal day yeah and
I had my dad every so many people play
to like my agent went out and played he
almost didn't go ahead at twist his arm
yeah yeah
it's yeah go up there I helped you drag
him up there I was like come on dude
yeah little wing or so Michael O'Brien
he [ __ ] ran up oh yeah hey Mike you
want any just ran right up he was great
two men so that was a [ __ ] great day
dude and your show was awesome and I
didn't know anything about efforts for
family before that night oh no you guys
played the the preview of it that was
the first time when I was like holy [ __ ]
this is gonna be awesome oh yeah so
right well we got another ten episodes
of that coming out but we're here just
we're here to uh promote your stuff
let's start with your website the real
Ben Bailey com that's your relaunch and
your website or you just I'm relaunching
it's been kind of just you know very
basic for a long time and I was like you
know what it it's time to just let's
start making my own stuff and putting it
out directly to people because there's
no reason to go and try and sell you
know like there's two short films on
there that I made that I really love
what's the one would Judah Friedlander
that you made a while ago I'm dying to
see that do it it's funny it's it's
called meet me at Ray's right and we
made it like way back in like 2002 or
something 2003 and we're crazy busy
after that and it just sat there and I'm
just I just looked at him like I got to
put this thing out so it's just about
two idiots meeting up for pizza at Ray's
pizza in New York you know but there's
there's a lot of Ray's pizzas
you got a little busy at 14 years later
I'm like all right let's put this thing
out and then well what happened during
those 14 years he started doing all the
movies you did the cash cab thing yeah
yeah that was so cool watching you guys
like blowing up like I felt like I'd
like our generation kind of had like an
even thing was just like nobody knew who
we were and then all of a sudden like
everybody started like just got some
inroads I don't know what happened yeah
yeah he felt like going to nowhere you
know I mean Jude and I used to sit in
his minivan at the end of the nights of
stand-up in the artist be like man this
is brutal we got nothing yeah got
nothing going on you know dude I
remember being in New York and then BOOM
and I moved back from LA the first time
I was out here and I had a I lost my
booking agent
I had no manager I had no agent and I
was incorporated as a business and I
just cost him
too much money I got unincorporated
right instead of paying to be in court
yeah because I wasn't making any money
and I went all the way back to square
one and I was living in that walkthrough
bedroom apartment with the guy who was
on the lease and it was me and Bobby
Kelly we had a lot of fun but there was
definitely nights it was probably good
that I was living with Bobby because
we'd laugh until you know you know the
late night and then I man take it easy
but if I had to go home and just be with
my own thoughts that happened that yeah
yeah after he moved out and then I moved
out and then there was that period about
2000 to 2004 where yeah there was a lot
of taste just waking up going like what
am i doing yeah what the [ __ ] I mean
dude I had I mean from 2000 2004 I think
somewhere in there I did get a half hour
right but there was like a thousand
remember right the guy came to your half
hour The Comedy Central one yeah I think
yeah there was like a good three year
period on yeah just being like okay 33
years old
yeah 34 years old 35 you know this was
not planned am I gonna be I thought it
was okay yeah yeah it was yeah and then
the whole alt scene was coming up yeah
and that whole thing blew up and then we
were just the [ __ ] housecats Bobby
that was that was rough man when the
alternative comedy club scene developed
and then just became this big thing you
couldn't drag yeah we're just in the in
the mainstream clubs like oops yeah like
no idea if you're not gonna move to
those places yeah man those were uh yeah
those are rough ones you know but we've
changed so you made that thing like 15
years ago what's this on the movie that
you have coming out because I know
you're owning this screening here which
is really cool this one's called blam
bangin badly-written action man yeah
yeah it's just I you know action movies
the action stars it there they are badly
written in a manner it's got a lot of
quality in those butts there but but
they're like one-liners are like at
least kind of clever witty you know yeah
even if they're over the Gulf some Steve
yeah totally so I was like I just
thought I thought of this character one
day I can't remember what I was doing
aware but I just like it'd be funny if
you know so much of those movies now are
built around those lines
if when you finally get to it with a you
know one of those lines it's just awful
just no payoff yeah it's just no payoff
at all you know which is like an anti
payoff really so it's kind of a crazy
concept but it just sort of fell
together like and how long are these
movies they're both about 10 minutes and
this is like the type of stuff you can
start putting on the real Ben Bailey
calm just yeah yeah yeah I think that's
a smart idea because those those shorts
I just liked about it they end up
turning into something they turn into
movies and uh that's one thing I've
learned about this business is it's just
like when you make that decision like if
this feels right I'm gonna do this so
many people they do it one two times and
when Spielberg Oh Oprah doesn't want to
interview you or some right like well
that sucks focus but I tried you just
got to keep going because then when one
of them hits then they go back to your
whole library yeah and you got all of
that stuff and they'll something will
will turn into a but um I hope you're
right about that dude hey how long have
you put a lot into them ym is about 10
minutes and it's and it's it's badly
written Action Man which was originally
badly written action star right and then
Lenny Marcus and I were working on
writing throwing around ideas about it
and he was abbreviating it when he wrote
back
it's a bwa s Blas or whatever right and
that made me go like oh maybe maybe
there's something in the acronym right
and then I was like oh if I make it
badly written Action Man then that's
blam and that's like a badly written
sound effect it's like hey no it just
kind of fell together you know when you
feel like something's working yeah I had
all these ideas and that one when doing
that little stuff like that just moved
to the front so I just made it when did
you shoot that one in July oh cool well
there you go now you've really stepped
it up yeah one took you 12 years this
one took you about 12 weeks ends on a
tear now Jesus Christ
but it's cool DC Benny's in it and I
loved he's a doctor he's in it he's a
great actor DC dude he's so good in this
he's so funny he's the evil villain in
in boy 1 oh man I'm gonna watch this
this is gonna be a it's in it vecchio
and it's in it
jams all right miss obvious in it sorry
I was late dude he'd be a perfect
henchman so yeah I'm a Savia how we know
him he used to run the old Boston Common
Club which is now
[ __ ] it was a wine tasting a wine bar
that's a wine bar yet I walked in there
one night just I had to go in and look
at it and there was all these you know
people in there you know 20s you know
primer their [ __ ] life like we used
to be and I just was going like you know
I can I help you sir I was just like
this old man they were like really and I
was like yeah I go I I watched like a 20
year old Dave Chappelle right where that
two top is and that was at first they
didn't give a [ __ ] till I dropped his
they said Chappelle even I was like all
offended like how come you don't know
what's important to me yeah I know that
I feeling yeah it's just like well cuz
we moved on old man now I like a merlot
I'll get the [ __ ] out of here leaving
I know downstairs of that place is now
the zinc bar that was used to be called
the beacon cafe used to be the the
baguette in the bag in it when we used
to drink in there
kinda hard I remember that kid with the
glasses the kid on the guitar he'd come
down and [ __ ] like wail like every
Monday night at Coker holy [ __ ] that guy
David Lee Coker yeah I've still been in
touch with him man he we did a song for
my last special Coker and I wrote a song
and did it and play it at the end - cat
blues silly like you know Cash Cab blues
to him right because the guy loved
Colker so much he's such a great
musician man you really how long you've
been playing by the way since I was 12
yeah well years old I the guy live
behind this English family moved in
behind us the Sedgwick's
and the old the old ships love ya hello
it sure yard is your garden Oregon oh I
was talking about that my last podcast
like every [ __ ] ingredient spice day
we say differently yeah so yeah there's
a lot of little basil oregano basil
dude my girlfriend you've met my girl
right she's Australian I have a new bit
around one of those little things that
that still come up these little
differences between how they speak and
how we speak and she said uh talking
about my daughter going horse riding
right and like horse riding
okay we say horseback riding and then
I'm like why do we specify yeah horse
riding actually makes a lot more sense
they kind of get we only ever ride on
one part of the horse before spec
writing yeah yeah but you said horse
riding get off its neck yeah yeah horse
neck has a whole bit about it but
there's so many little things like that
but so he's pretty got this British
family moves in behind us the oldest
brother is like I'm like I'm 11
what are their names again the
Sedgewick's I just want he said Andrew
Sedgwick Cedric just olt is with the
urgency of that accent is just [ __ ]
tremendous but it's not fair is that
there's so much gravitas yeah that comes
with that accent it just we can't sound
so [ __ ] important everything I say
yeah sorry no that's fine do did so the
oldest brother is like 25 or 26 and he's
a sound engineer so he's got a studio in
their attic he builds a studio in their
attic and he's working on doing sound
mixing for some albums like some pretty
big stuff like them what was his name
his name was Andrew Sedgwick no but so I
would go over there and annoy the [ __ ]
out of his guy who's a little kid who I
was so curious about it all his
equipment and stuff his studio and
everything that he got fed up with me
asking him a zillion questions and he
just put a guitar in my hand here play
with this so I started playing with it
and you know six months later I bought
it I saved up my my paper route
and I bought his oh you had a paper
route oh yeah yeah oh you say route I
say Brook look at that route route I
never wait which one did I say you said
route
I thought route was Midwest I don't
we'll see I have a little Midwest I
lived in Michigan when I was when I was
little well I didn't know I know I have
this weird mix of accents the other than
the South too so I gotta go be a brat or
something no my dad he's a killer so how
many times were you the new kid in
school
uh four I did it three times
it's brutal [ __ ] brutal right I still
remember the kids that were nice to me
yeah I still remember when I moved the
last time we moved
oh maybe the second time there's kid
Keith Hannon the first recess goes hey
man you want to play catch
he had a tennis ball like I was just
like oh thank bad enough it was bad
enough coming in like we were like 40 we
moved to the town we were like four days
we were it was already four days ago it
we're right yeah then we came and I had
a very similar thing man and how they
bring you in he's like you don't just
[ __ ] like I didn't just show up I didn't
get on the bus or anything like that
like we went down to the principal's
office cuz we were late and everything
and they were like alright and then just
walked us down and she just came walking
and going okay class we have a new
student they're all looking at like I
kind of like energy duay through the
last one I hung my coat up like a re
I've made a lot of noise I went over and
I sat down and then that's why I just
sat down I felt like course my desk I
felt was like right in the middle of the
class
I just felt everybody glancing me I was
like with my [ __ ] orange hair like I
know I know I don't like it either [ __ ]
off so that's brutal being the new kid
is [ __ ] hard I was all like I was a
big kid kinda at that age yeah high
school oh I wasn't that big mm-hmm
everyone sort of caught up with me and
then I drew again later but when I was
in fourth grade I was one of the bigger
kids so it seems I'm gonna be great but
note that all the kids who were the
bigger guys want I had to like fight
them yeah I had to fight my way through
first day of school they were people
were choosing who I had to fight on the
[ __ ] playground like this is not lost
I always I thought this kid I remember
what this kid this is sort of kind of
when I look about like it was sort of
racist the way the teacher handle it he
was the only black kid and for some
reason we fought we fought like five
recesses in a row and he kept kicking my
ass and finally I remember I was
starting to win and he had these [ __ ]
work boots on and then you just went
like bam bam bam like three times in my
[ __ ] I was like crying right I was just
sitting there crying I remember she
[ __ ] as we used to say back then
bawled him out is what we Sicilian
yelled at she bawled yelled at him and
then came out I was sitting there crying
she came home and she like rubbed my
head she even thought so you just got
away with it but I was kind of like
maybe because you lost Oh cuz I was so
pathetic or maybe I just look like a
little bit a little beat up Ron Howard I
don't know what Ralph Malph or something
there there ginger yeah
I actually thought about later like why
was she comforting me we both got into
it every [ __ ] recess I was clearly
not like trying innocent to get away
from the kid I don't even know why we
will fight neither cuz then we ended up
being like friends it was just like that
little kid [ __ ] yeah and I still
remember somehow I slipped and fell and
when I did during the fight yeah yeah I
think he fell down to maybe we just like
with the heel of his boot tongue
sticking out you know little kids when
they're really trying to make an effort
crime I even if I won the fights when I
was a kid
Oh cuz just the emotions just I wish I
was at a birthday party we were playing
street hockey and this one kid who
played hockey was like really good he
kept lifting my stick and kept taking
the puck and he was like [ __ ] twice my
height oh my god knocking your stick up
yeah that guy's so mad I turn around I
just started fighting him and he just he
just kind of like he'd like leaned back
and kind of like let me [ __ ] get like
3/4 in like missing kinda and then he
just went
blam and fast blasted me in the side of
the head and I fell down I started
crying I walked away and I just remember
screaming the top of my lungs and I was
walkin I used to cut through the woods
right and people were yelling from the
Guardi to get to school like you know
I'd cut through the woods to get to my
friend's house where you played street
hockey I was already into the woods and
people were screaming ok come on come
back and I was in the middle of was very
sad [ __ ] his mother yelled one time and
this is maturity of the other kid this
is no just see I walk it through the
trail yeah it was always such a real
moment yes like I live the same thing
like and what was funny was I came home
and I told my mother what happened and
it never dawned on her to call over
there to drive me all that all that
overly just getting involved with [ __ ]
parenting that people yeah have done
over the last like what ever since we
were kids
alright see when you get home yeah well
you know I have things to do or whatever
and then that was kind of it and I
remember the next day the maturity of
the other kid was when we were on the
bus I was like ignoring him and stuff or
he just kind of yelled that we know
everybody stands up he waiting to get
off the bus he yell hey but let me talk
to you we get off the bus I was like are
we go after well that's cool yeah dude
this is fifth grade he really just goes
like yes sorry about that guy man that's
impressive yet I should have learned
that less but I didn't because [ __ ] that
kid huh no I his name you remember his
name
yeah I don't want to say everybody's not
probably I said because people get all
weird and [ __ ] still rubber actually
real people are still alive yeah his
first name was Tom put it that way the
tall [ __ ] dude dude I was way out of
my [ __ ] way class like he even even
the ass-kicking was a gentlemanly
ass-kicking he just gave me one shut the
[ __ ] us to sit down quiet little kid
yeah there was no reason for me to fight
you I was just mad cuz he was better
than me it was really immature even for
that age I'm still ashamed of myself so
so anyway so this guy didn't have given
you a guitar that's really [ __ ] cool
yeah it was so cool I guess yeah hey I
got it well he mean I could go over
there and play it whenever but but at
some point I was like I'm gonna save up
and buy it I think I bought it for like
75 bucks did he he teach any chords or
anything or is he no no he just left me
to it you know but then I like my girl
my sister's boyfriend was a guitar
player and he was quite a bit older and
like so he showed me some stuff and
pretty soon I was like you know I knew I
could figure out some songs I always had
a decent ear I could pick stuff out and
find it but that was you that was unless
you had the money to take lessons that
was the only way to learn back then that
was ice and snow you know like kids
today the [ __ ] that they can see on
YouTube someone just totally break that
thing down yeah which is greatly
everything yeah which is great that's
why there's so many monster players out
there but like I would suggest if you
know as they start to show it to sort of
turn you back to the screen see if you
can just listen to what he's doing and
just just so you're always developing
your because yeah I would want to be
that guy like you know couldn't figure
it out like yeah well that's like it was
like you're a littering it out yeah you
know but I also think that
maybe one sort of downfall of of
everything being out there for anybody
to learn is you don't develop your own
style of guitar like or whatever it is
right like I play guitar differently
than most people I think because I no
one ever really taught me how to play I
just started playing it right so I have
little little things that I do that are
probably unique to me at least I hope
they are right it's not a technique guy
would be like actually that says yeah
that's wrong you're holding your hand
wrong or you know you know it still
sounds good but yeah they're like well
but it's this is what I do so you know
but I think music is like that you know
it's it's your expression whatever
whatever you do that's what you do so
yeah it's it's definitely a it's kind of
a great thing for it and it's also a
weird thing because then I definitely
there's always like then there's like
the top like [ __ ] it's just I think I
feel like everybody's influence now is
is whatever subject it is the first page
the first three links right becomes like
90% of people's like consciousness
because if you look at I should probably
cuz I even do that should probably want
to go on YouTube next time I go to look
something up to try to just click to
like like what the [ __ ] is on page three
yeah like I want to get into the age of
99 yeah this you want the hell's on
there the underground yeah there's a
hundred thousand pages to look at of
most things right thousand hits on how
to play you know yeah I played I played
right before I came over here I'm doing
another one of those really the goddamn
Comedy Jam so I have another song I got
I gotta try to get together with what
song where you can't say yet I don't a
ruin it cuz it's because it's part of
the show and they get there but it's you
know I always stay pretty much you know
70s and 80s right I dress up like the
drummer that I'm gonna so it's just
completely ridiculous yeah cuz they tell
you what to do I want to do one of those
with those guys I gotta I gotta connect
with them yeah cuz they were like you
should do one when you come out in X but
now it's been a year yeah you'd kill it
I'd be so fun dude I wonder if I don't
know if Josh and those guys came up for
the the Toyota and now New York Comedy
Festival I think they were there I think
they were in New York for that dude I
have so much fun with those guy there
him one year I did Montreal the [ __ ]
Comedy Festival just to come and I
played with those guys three nights in a
row oh it's just to do it and then I
then I did a stand-up show but like the
reason I was there
what's to do the music yeah because I
played dude I played for [ __ ] like 20
years by myself yeah
like it was so - same thing man but it
was such like a like a kind of thing of
like why I ended up becoming a comedian
because I was so introverted and like it
didn't dawn on me until like the
mid-2000s I started playing in the 80s
that was just like right hey kind of the
reason for playing is to interact with
other humans yeah to share it with
people yeah yeah and then thank God that
that show came around and the first time
I got there like well I sat in with a
few other people but the first time I
actually kind of came out people knew
who [ __ ] I wasn't at sit down it was it
was a really like was such a fun thing
so Music Live is different than stand-up
obviously but it's so great but I think
I just love it man it it's fun for us
too because we're not in a band and we
don't have to deal with that because I
know that guys I've met they're actually
in bands it's like the big thing is how
to keep it fun and big when it starts
becoming a job like you've toured with
other comedians and you know when you're
with comedians you're gonna have the
substance abuse guy you have the [ __ ]
hound a late guy big egomaniac those are
all the same guy yeah that's all Tony
woods we all have a couple of those I'm
wondering I'm war two of those guys from
time to time but yeah I mean what - are
you would you say I'm late and what were
the other ones substance abuse egomaniac
[ __ ] hound I would say I am definitely
late and maybe a touch of substance
abuse I'm dumb substance abuse cigars
drinking yeah I can you I don't know if
this makes me [ __ ] up or anything but
like I know I could shut it off any time
I want to I just don't want to what do
you mean the drinking or their yeah yeah
it's okay I could go I did it I did it
you know I know you went a few years I
went to I did like a year and some
change you know you're in a couple of
days I was just like I just I missed it
yeah but it's not something it like
completely like ruins my ruins my
like I don't know I mean I I know when
to do it
I do much much more controlled than I
used to like when I stopped I stopped
because I was like holy [ __ ] this is I'm
out of control here all right I got it I
got it way off and and regain my footing
so oh yeah that's like five years I
think I think that's the difference
between like maybe attics and like
[ __ ] up people like you and I where
it's just like I can just I just want to
get side of controls like I'm not gonna
do that for like a month you know stop
for a while yeah although this year you
know I kept saying that and was never a
month it was always HIPPA like three
four days stressful year this year just
a lot of stuff just doubt it's just like
career stop being busy being busy busy
and all my free time kind of [ __ ]
yeah dissolved and uh sitting there you
know writing on a show it's just you
come home your brain is fried and I
probably should have picked a better
habit but it started to be coming coming
home and having a whiskey right and then
it became too and then it became three
my wife is finally like hey you [ __ ]
booze bag what are you doing it
literally called me a boost bag and then
I then I I I dialed it back and for me
it's just it's it's could you like
laughs when she'd said that oh god yeah
yeah you weren't like that's good no my
wife is it for Larry what you know
you've got all mad wait a minute I know
yes I did that now that's a bet if
that's your reaction and you need to
think about it yes standing there like
yeah you're right I need to write it in
sorry then you're then it's cool yeah I
just had a couple of bottles hidden
behind toilets and [ __ ]
that's totally that's totally normal no
I think that I think everybody that guy
needs to have some little [ __ ] that's
just there's like like a little thing
that you keep just for you know you have
to do right you know what I mean like
everybody's got a maybe some secret
little [ __ ] that or just dares whatever
it is I saw this guy one time this old
dude I'm gonna move the mic here I'm
sorry I got a lean back at some point
have bad posture I saw this one time I
was staying at this hotel right right
and there was his old dude standing
there all right and like every night
like clockwork
because I would finish the shows I'd
come home he come walking out of
someone's hotel as you could hear a
little dog or whatever nowadays
things like a [ __ ] therapy dog so you
can get away with it it's a working dog
working dad you're not supposed to ask
yeah I asked the guy in the airport he's
like you're not supposed to ask about it
well I did I'm like yeah well if he
didn't have a sweater that said working
dog on it I wouldn't have [ __ ] asked
ya what's its job what's did it major in
business um every night this guy would
come out and he would he'd take out a
little pouch it was tobacco by the way
he'd take that out and he would roll his
own cigarette and it was I just saw it
was like this is this guy's whole ritual
you know sat there and he would only
smoke one breath and he would just he
would milk it and he would make it last
for like a half hour he would just sit
out there quietly no phone no iPad no
nothing and I remember seeing that going
like yeah I get what that guy is doing
here and I wish I had the time to do to
do a little more that we just have that
that I think guys kind of need like
alone time I don't know how women are
women are a little more social but I
agree they probably needed to I have no
idea I shouldn't speak for them I don't
know I my girl seems content to just be
together and then you know and talk and
chat about everything all the time and
sometimes I'm like why am I getting all
cranky and [ __ ] up right now I'm like
I just need to be by myself like I need
to I definitely need a long time I think
that's why we've got a million things
going on you know we also are these
careers are all-consuming if you let
them be right because we don't have an
office we don't punch a clock we don't
show up at one time and then leave at
another it's just always going on right
you have ideas you have creative ideas
you have schedule [ __ ] that you're
keeping things going on when I shot my
special right on the 21st of October I
was like oh this year just shot a new
one yep and I my stick all I gotta do is
just [ __ ] you know edit that thing
look at it a couple times cuz I know
what I want right and I'm again I'm just
[ __ ] done man I'm have time to
Christmas shop I'm gonna [ __ ] put my
feet up play some drums and blah blah
blah blah I mean I don't know I don't
know what's happening I'm [ __ ] more
uh more busy than ever and it's just
like all of these uh I don't know I just
I don't know editing what's good is
gonna take a while bro yeah but I've
been able to do it this time where I sat
through and I watched the whole [ __ ]
thing which is something I you know
you for a [ __ ] hour and a half and
the longer you watch it you like it's
not even funny anymore yeah you can't
get yet it's like oh my god it's an old
bit or yes yeah [ __ ] but every time I go
to do one is like a major like I say you
know you donate a kidney he just adds
always a chunk I'm like get that the
[ __ ] out of there and just go right to
the end and then we're done and today I
figured out what it was and it went from
you know well I felt a little bit too
long to now being like [ __ ] it's over
already which is that's we perfect
that's a sweet spot yeah you know you
don't want it
um it's it's about seventy seven okay so
that's about our 50 and I was 16 but I
mean it was getting away it was getting
like when they took all the footage from
both shows it was like like an hour 38
I'm like alright there's no way so we
cut it down then was like 129 and I'm
like but I like everything but I'm just
saying yeah I think you have to if you
like release like a concert movie I
think it's got to be I would think like
90 minutes if people just you yeah and
it's meant to be a feature I just feel
like Netflix if you're gonna go on there
and people are gonna sit down if you're
lucky enough if you're lucky enough that
are actually gonna click on your [ __ ]
it's just that you just gotta like you
got to go ACDC on him you know where
they don't play any ballads you just got
a [ __ ] Jew yeah yeah unless you like
Chapelle which Chapelle has that way
where he can just really [ __ ] like
bring it down like he just watching him
do that opening monologue on SNL I mean
just like yeah the level of [ __ ] that
he's doing effortlessly not even
consciously the ups and downs peaks and
valleys and then the huge laughs and
then the poignant moments and all of
that it's just like that that was you
know I'd be happy if I could have done
in an hour and a half what the [ __ ] he
didn't like eight minutes that clinic
that he that he put on so yeah he's
amazing super talented guy man always
was yeah always was when he was standing
where someone's drinking as white
zinfandel right now the Boston Comedy is
Club is hey so what did you were you
shocked about the election
results I wasn't that shocked I was we
finally met somebody who called it I
knew somebody had to bet Trump I didn't
bet Trump I didn't want to bet Trump but
I did a tour I was on tour in a lot of
southern states mm-hmm for you know a
month leading up to the election and
nothing but Trump signs all right I mean
that's all it's not how much she
couldn't see a single Hillary son I saw
hundreds of Trump signs and I was like
this this could just might be real do
never in a million years did I think I
thought the Hillary was the made person
at the idea George it was funny I did I
did a Conan the day after the election
and like you know I got so many people
like [ __ ] yelling at me thinking
about how the [ __ ] could you say this
about Hillary how the [ __ ] you say it
about Trump like you can't say anything
about anybody I try to evenly trash both
of them and just say hey it'd be nice if
people stop yelling at each other
somehow people missed all of that yeah
and they they you know I think
especially a Hillary people because it's
so disappointed that they just need
somebody I got it's so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
from people and actually it affects me
going like hey man I saw you on that and
I go the guy was like it seemed like you
know secretly you voted for Trump
then he wrote secretly no it's just like
yeah like no I didn't vote for that guy
no I didn't vote for either one of them
I couldn't stand them I like Barney
Barney was my [ __ ] guy I felt like
right after the election for the first
time I felt like Bernie would have won I
was like people really want to change
you know they don't same old with
Hillary yeah and if the if I was like
holy [ __ ] if Bernie had gotten the
nomination he would probably be the
president right now people think Joe
Biden could have won I think just like
like I don't like familiarity breeds
contempt maybe everybody's [ __ ]
filthy there was just something about
like I felt myself saying it like it
when I saw Jeb Bush and I saw Kleenex I
can't deal with another bush or a
Clinton yeah that's a stupid thing to
say but I was just saw it's true there's
some truth to it because they're my
somebody else to lie to me now
I don't want this guy yeah I didn't want
this guy you know I'm not saying Bernie
would have [ __ ] solved everything I
will say all this [ __ ] that Trump's
doing is [ __ ] hilarious what he's
like I'm gonna do this don't do that
I'm gonna drain the swamp it's like dude
okay let's just say you actually go in
there and you somehow do this house low
DC works like you're gonna [ __ ] drain
the swamp and then what expose all these
people and then they're all gonna go to
jail and like that and they're gonna be
okay with this
ya know I'm gonna get all the illegal
immigrants out of this country you're
gonna do how are you gonna do that how
are you gonna do that yeah yeah I'm
gonna build a [ __ ] wall from here to
[ __ ] in California to Texas
are you really you're gonna you gonna do
all of this there I think there already
is a wall for one isn't there there's
already a fence and a wall through a lot
of it it's like definitely at road here
stop people from coming in by blocking
off three percent of the of the border
it's so tiny it's like they're coming in
any way they could come in well I
thought he was gonna fence the whole
basis of the country he wasn't people
get to come in from all over the [ __ ]
points well there is I actually think
about that [ __ ] it's like there does
become the tipping point well you got
too many [ __ ] people yeah there is
that I mean back in the day yeah we need
him you know we needed all we could get
because of what we were doing which was
underhanded we missed what Amory was
great but we needed to take all this
yeah yeah get out there in the front
lines you snuck him out west day that's
your land over there go over there and
then provoke them into an attack like
what the whole [ __ ] thing was shady
yeah from the beginning yeah it's not
him goes for elections well you know
it's crazy government they're they've
been corrupt and been [ __ ] up since
the beginning like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna say the show but I recently did a
show right and one of the comics went up
and this person went and just trashed
Donald Trump this is after after the
show after the election or the show
after the show they went after the show
after the election right it was like the
you know four five days after whatever
they went right and went in hard on
Trump Bible by he's a sex offender and
then are all this type of stuff and
gradually the crowd started booing right
half the crowd half the crowd [ __ ]
booze so then the next person goes up it
was a trump supporter this person goes
up and supports Trump and trashes
Hillary than the other
half of the crowd started booing them
I've never seen like so divided dude
it's literally like it's like a great
SCC football game where they playing
like a neutral site like when Florida
plays in Georgia and like it's half the
[ __ ] Bulldogs half Gators it's
[ __ ] insane like I've never just like
that if the country is so completely
divided that it's a little scary but the
thing that I don't like is that now the
people you know whatever side you're on
where you're seeing the other side as
your enemy right when we're not supposed
to be enemies we're all supposed to we
only hear together
dude that ship sailed it I know that's
what I'm saying that's what's shitty
once news came in and balanced out CNN
by being just as ridiculously far to the
other side I mean those shows those
those networks that are hilarious like
we're not on election night what I would
do is I would just whoever was winning I
would watch the other Network just to
watch some stars to see what they said
yeah and just go no I just just for the
comedy of it because I knew there was
nothing nothing I mean I voted foo I
wanted to vote for I knew this [ __ ]
state was gonna go with Hillary Clinton
I mean that's a that's a given the
oceans vote for blue and everybody else
in the middle votes for red and then it
comes down to like [ __ ] Ohio
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin evidently
North Carolina which I didn't know about
that but what I was happy was actually
was up to date on all the propositions
and voted read em all me and my wife
will read them for like days in front
and like we just laughing her ass off
like you do we sit there like reading
there'd be like you know do you not want
them to drill for oil in the middle of
your forehead and then here's the
argument for and be like well that would
probably lead to your death there is no
oil in there blah blah blah blah and
then it'd be like the argument gets
actually it's the complete opposite the
drilling for oil would actually save
this to sit next thing either you know
maybe i should vote like i didn't get
anything out of those arguments and then
we were just laughing we did you just
eventually look at well who supported
this it'd be like if it was anything
environmentally it's like Ed Begley Jr
alright that guy's been riding a bike
for 30 years okay if he's down with this
I'm going with that bag his powers whole
neighborhood fight right now yeah on a
hamster wheel you know it's funny do we
know who what happened with the condoms
in porno did that pass or no
nice actually a thing yes keep porn I'll
keep some jobs here and in in the valley
fight so no they don't have to work on
them so now I think that that was like
ever they do they do okay oh this is
classic Americans we don't even know
we're gonna look it up I thought it used
to be that way
and now that they've taken it you could
not be further off the mic so you got to
make a quick point here okay so porno
permits we're saying that maybe it
passed but they can't get permits oh
Jesus Christ there's only had two things
to vote on other than offices we had to
vote on whether or not we wanted to
allow casinos in northern Jersey and
what'd you say I said no which and and
it didn't it was no it's overwhelming no
they're not gonna be able to put casinos
in northern Jersey which is in my
opinion very good right I would hate
casinos chris christie's but i don't
think they should be everywhere chris
Christie is fat and I caught he's fat
enough he doesn't mean to get that that
skinbag going to Jersey Mike's even more
and the other one was like should we
designate the money from tolls and fuel
tax into trans public transportation
which is first question it's a B for to
begin with first question is where is it
going now well anywhere else I don't
know where I don't I really don't know
where but it was meant to be allocated
toward that a certain percentage of it
initially and then that got changed
somewhere along the line so ours was
like voted changed it back was
legalizing weed keeping it legal or
something like that it was the condoms
it was like should we repaired there was
one about building up schools and
everything we're initially you're like
yeah this is a good thing and then but
the whole thing the whole proposition
was written by these group of people
that are builders well wait a minute I
don't like that the contractors are
writing this [ __ ] up so what's going on
with this they want there's a lot of
interesting [ __ ] oh yeah that wasn't
allowed yeah no I can't remember there
was like it was like at least another
twelve there was so many I need a vote
on every one of them yeah but was great
was we've figured out the best we could
what it was and God knows what is
attached to all of that [ __ ] to it you
know what I mean so I had all my answers
before I went in there so what was
taking everybody like you know a good 20
minutes if you're reading it for the
first [ __ ] time I Adam also I would
just look at the page yes was up Noah's
down I would just look at my answer
sheet I'd be like up down down up and I
just that was great I was cheating on a
test well let before we get out every we
got to get the answer here what's going
on it did not pass it did not pass it
did not pass they can't get their
permits to make porn of them yeah even
that is cop who's who's a conservative
behind that that wants to get porno out
of the valley did did tipper gore moved
to the valley recently remember
her--they and PRC so one way one guy
wrote in it that does not sound real so
like I could do that he's the one guy
who supplies the porno but hey it has to
get it's got to get through some sort of
[ __ ] legislative horse [ __ ] right
today and get put on the ballot so he's
got money yeah alright because I would
say then the guy who said the rents too
damn high what he got something done
remember that guy yeah yeah and the rent
is too damn high I hate it when like he
kept getting laughs and kept hanging
around and then like one of those
politicians like I agree with them the
rent is too darn high I don't know how
those politicians exist in that level
only cartoons yeah yeah I'll go is one
of the most was the one of the worst I
saw that was the thing I think about
Trump that was amazing was watching him
just be a be himself which a lot of
people don't like who he was but he was
being a person a lot of people don't
think a good person but like he's candid
you can't you can't accuse him of not
being me dude it was like they was
sitting at the table but it was
politicians and he was the guy running
the table and no one could get him I
couldn't [ __ ] him none they could not
figure out they're like this guy doesn't
care about anything
how do we pin him down
he didn't give a [ __ ] about what he says
from one minute to the next
he didn't care about her like oh oh
she's allowed to talk and I can I'll
great three against one
what he said that it was it was [ __ ]
because it's very ticket but it was
brilliant like do what he did I mean I'm
not happy that it's certainly these
[ __ ] guys that he's putting together
I joked to my last podcast you know he
was talking he's gonna have change and
everything that was just going just
doing the exact time it's like fuller
house yes bring it back this old show it
was like the expendable version of the
Expendables of Republicans it's just
dude it's the whole thing to him was
just a game it seems if you talk if you
see him interviewed now it's just like
he's basically like oh I won and that
was it it doesn't matter how you guys
just won you must wait about the summer
and they're like but you're gonna you're
doing all this stuff that you just said
you weren't gonna do he's like well who
else is gonna do it basically it's like
Marx Brothers [ __ ] like you can't just
say who else but the thing about the
media is they had no follow-up cuz they
never dealt with a guy like this who
would just admit to yeah like you know
yeah typical follow-up doesn't work
because they call him out on it and he
just says yeah whatever who cares and it
says something else well the the back in
the day when somebody would call when
they would call a politician out they'd
try to get out of it and they would
stammer and then they would just keep
you know hitting them with it until just
the whole embarrassment of the situation
the person would drop out he just would
admit to it and they had nothing yeah
and they're like well when they said no
he's just supposed to be bad I keep
using this as an example that would like
you you know you've said this about
women you've said that about women you
said this opponent is not anti cuz I
said that about Rosie O'Donnell and it
got a huge laugh and then the female
reporter goes like now you've said that
about other women to what he just
because he's probably right it's over
and it was over he'd make a joke and she
couldn't even like or anybody in that
panel couldn't have been like you're
probably right so you're saying you are
sexist is that what you're saying do you
think that like and then I still think
because of what the [ __ ] represented
he could have just been like yes I am
sexist yeah I can't believe you're not
sitting here making me a pie
or something they get out of here and
let the men handle it clearly people
were not put off by that but it's so
hard to tell what's what's true and what
is it anything you read about Hillary in
the last three months or five months or
whatever could have been taken out of
context absolutely put in a way to make
her look you know show her in a certain
light and same with Trump it's be silly
to assume that one side is doing it one
side the other is not no they are like
you don't amazing it's very difficult to
tell what the [ __ ] is real and what
isn't you know you know it's funneled
out there news from [ __ ] Twitter
Facebook all of that I um you know
chummy Obed daily on Twitter by the way
real been Billy be real Ben Bailey Bai
lui calm the real Ben Bailey calm I um I
was actually amazed the election night
when they had the pictures of each
candidate and was finally won that the
other side hadn't picked I was just like
okay Lurie she looks like a nice person
look at Donald it looks like a cool guy
yeah they look Donald was always like
you know the scowl he had like the thing
like that rudy giuliani picture that the
left is using where he looks like he's
roaring he just came up from the flames
of hell that thing is [ __ ] you could
you can do that to anybody especially
yeah totally and when you're that old
that you know it's such an effort just
to speak your face is gonna contort they
just have to do take a couple of
pictures you're gonna look like Satan
and then Hillary always just had that
crazy [ __ ] smile and the bobblehead
thing going and done really unflattering
white like she looked like you know I'll
do they did every Skeletor they did
everything they possibly could to both
of them like Trump like his eyebrows by
the end of the election were like
beneath his eyes say well Frank it's
joke the fact that he actually has won
points out the point that he made
repeatedly through the campaign which is
at the whole systems is [ __ ] it
doesn't work yeah but I will tell you
all those people that think that he's
somehow gonna get them out of their
[ __ ] hole is that's it's ridiculous
no you know it's they don't give it it's
on you it's on you and they they try to
act like these these people are gonna
save you [ __ ] ass they're not no they
can't you know and that's the uplifting
message of this podcast
could be worse dude there's a there's
like a billion people literally a
billion people in China that live in
abject poverty I've told and are
brainwashed into thinking that that's
you know that's their place I don't know
it's a billion people how would you even
begin to have you seen this is the thing
tackle up an issue like that
have you seen no way to do it it's it's
just that's a that's how it is have you
seen those cities like but they're they
have a few cities over there that have
so many [ __ ] people like it literally
looks like there's a fire but it's just
the polluted air it's just the area it's
just the air so like when they were
having the Olympics over there at some
point when they were gonna shoot
something you know film it for the world
to see they told everybody to like not
drive or use any machinery or anything
god knows what would happen to you if
you did like I don't know 24 hours of
three days or some [ __ ] before they just
let all of that [ __ ] in the air just
settle down onto the ground because
that's that's what it is
yeah cuz it's all like even like out
here like blood times people think the
haze is smog but like haze like smog is
brown but haze is that clear thing and
that haze is all the dust and all the
[ __ ] that we're kicking out to drive
around yeah so everybody I bet I think
basically what's that new thing the kids
are doing you act like a mannequin or
some [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah they made
like the a billion people or half a
billion people [ __ ] do that people go
swimming you guys just have to hold
still yeah until we're done with the
100-meter back there's a couple more
things on there though you have any
lecture any more movies or something
like do you know like the next one that
you're gonna do as far as the short film
I don't I think I might do another
episode of blam I like I'd like it a lot
and it was really fun and like the idea
was that another comic or you know actor
friend of mine will be they be the
villain probably another comedian and so
we'll just keep doing those but I can
definitely see that being a series it
web series a webisode it was an
initially was gonna be a web series but
then I made the first one and I was like
I don't know if I want to put all that
into this every single time just on my
own right I might rat at Rice
other stuff and see what people like you
know get some feedback once the stuff is
out there any guff that leads to
something the next thing you know yeah
you have something on you got something
on [ __ ] Amazon or Netflix yeah thank
you walking down a red carpet people
yelling Ben what are you wearing what
are you wearing
I don't know and then they go back then
they go back through all yours and a
recently unearthed gem meet at Ray's
face and you said well so I have yeah
for 12 years now it's a period film well
I actually was anyway I want to see it
because I want to see like because I'm
I'm one of those guys that I love seeing
New York and you love into any era that
it isn't now like I love seeing it in
the 90s now I love seeing it in the 80s
I love seventies of this [ __ ] and then
the 60s and 50s when it goes back is
yeah like i watch i watch old [ __ ]
movies for that reason like sometimes I
watch an old movie I'll see a guy
driving down Sunset and you just see how
spread out the buildings are yeah yeah
and I mean of the shooting so you don't
know about the traffic but it's just
like some of that stuff where it's just
you could just so see the hills and
stuff it's like yeah that back then
that's why they had like you want to go
shoot a mountain lion and you like
walked out your backyard it's right he's
just right down the road yeah in in LA
so anyway so I should say I or before we
go sorry I also have to podcast shows
that are gonna be on this on a new
website oh cool
one of them's a storytelling show
beautify remember DC Benny and I used to
do that show urban myth yeah wait a
bleep what venue did did that was that I
just almost got to this early on we're
talking about zinc bar because that was
the original zinc bar was on Houston
Street yes and that's where I would do
urban myth every Tuesday the new podcast
I have is called tall but true it's a
storytelling show it's but it's pretty
much servin myth oh cool has a podcast
so it's like the two of us tell a story
and then a guest tells a story so love
to have you do that yeah man call in to
that if you want and then another one
and that'll all be on the real Ben
Bailey calm yeah and then one where my
girl and I it's called speaking of
movies we watch a movie and then we just
talk about the movie afterward those are
all good we love which we did anyway and
then one day we're like we always have
these great conversations after we watch
a movie let's just start recording them
so can you
amenda movie you've seen lately that you
liked dude I watched you've probably
seen it I'm Way behind but I just
watched Batman vs Superman I liked it
I've loved it man you've already seen it
oh yeah yeah it was great I liked it I
said that yesterday at Benson's podcast
Doug loves movies and everybody's like
what they were like they thought it was
turning to what I like the boat is
awesome I like the movies sorry I like
the how the way they had are like the
the government getting involved going we
here just have this guy acting
unilaterally and whatever the [ __ ] that
means you know just just basically
helping out what the [ __ ] he wants and
people claiming him and all that I was
just going on account of all this really
yeah that actually seemed like some [ __ ]
that they would do and then demonize him
and all that like I always forget movies
the second I saw him but that thing
stuck out with me I I really liked that
I thought it was great man and it's it's
you know if you ever seen Watchmen I
remember that one that's the same
director Zack Snyder I think his name is
he made the Watchmen there's a which is
like super dark superhero movie right
based on this graphic novel which is
awesome you should check it out you'd
love it there's a gator called the
comedian oh cool superhero called the
comedian he's like super dark
the only thing I don't like about
Superman movies is it always comes down
to the Kryptonite it's always it's never
you know bangs the wrong girl it's you
just know okay where's when's the green
chain getting wrapped around his neck
here what's it gonna happen yeah the
only thing that can do it the only thing
he's too powerful that's the thing it
almost gets a little boring well well
Ben we finally got you on the podcast I
finally got the plate jam with you man
it was [ __ ] awesome and continued
success
check out all things Ben Bailey at the
real Ben Bailey calm you can also get
there by going to 3b TV net that's three
baby t v-- combi isn't baby I should say
doesn't it dotnet sorry unfortunately
it's not man dot now I'm is like some
kids who have a site with funny videos
that suck I shouldn't that's me I know I
know what you're okay but it's not mine
you went you went for the joke that
three B TV dotnet all right I'm gonna
read a little bit of advertising and
that's gonna be it I hope you guys have
a good weekend I'll I'll see on Monday
you [ __ ] comments
[Music]
all right here's the advertising here
Nia can you stop moving this [ __ ] around
track her we're all losers Newsweek
reports the average American wastes 55
minutes a day looking for things they
own but can't find get the [ __ ] out of
here 55 minutes I'm a dope I look for 48
[ __ ] Newsweek no kitty share a story of
when you've lost something you needed I
remember one time I was taking a dump
but I was like where's the toilet paper
so I'm walking around with my [ __ ]
belt around my legs tracker makes losing
things a thing of the past and I'll tell
you how to get one for free in a minute
tracker is a coin size device that's
locates misplace keys wallets bags
computers anything in seconds just pair
tracker to you smatphone attach it to
anything and find its precise locations
with the tap of a button it's that easy
lose your phone oh [ __ ] there it is
press a button on tracker and your phone
rings even if it's when it's on silent
creepy tracker is finding over a million
misplaced items each day order yours and
never lose anything again listeners get
listeners listeners to this show
[ __ ] get a free tract or a Bravo with
any order go to the tracker comm and
enter the promo code BRR
the hardest thing a level F you'll ever
have to find is their website go to
tracker calm right now and enter the
promo code / for your free copy what
free tracker Bravo with any order again
that's tracker comm promo code berm hey
where's the next read oh there it is
Thank You tracker lift you know about
lift right it's the app that gets your
rides in minutes on-demand 24/7 for less
than the cost of a cab if you tried lyft
you know what I mean but lyft you just
download the app request a driver they
show up in three and a half minutes on
average
that's really fast in case you didn't
know there every lift driver is fully
vetted through their ten-point safety
standard have you ever killed anyone
- idiot jerk off when you're driving
three right they go through the whole
thing so you'd be safe including
criminal and DMV background checks
you'll know you'll get around quickly
and safely why can't I read tonight lyft
drivers are rated after every ride it's
only the best stick around you don't
have to worry about getting into a
filthy card with some creepy dude with
lifts you can tip in the app with
obviously leads to happier drivers I
mean 9 out of 10 lift rides get a
perfect 5 star rating from the
passengers it's just better all-around
experience what happens on that tenth
one we'll leave that up bigger isn't
always better
you [ __ ] size Queen lyft isn't the
biggest ride-sharing app but it's the
fastest growing in the highest-rated one
I'm talking quality over quantity you
know where they're taking a shot at here
it rhymes with scoober um thanks to lift
you got an easy way to avoid drunk
driving you never have to bum a ride and
you never have to worry about parking a
lot of people are actually getting ride
getting rid of their cars and relying on
lyft to get around and you know what I
don't blame them what if I didn't say
that you wrote that well if you live in
Nebraska I think you're out of your
[ __ ] mind right now lyft is offering
our listeners a special deal get three
rides up to ten dollars each that's a
$30 value you get those for free when
you enter the promo code bill burr just
download for free the lyft app today and
enter the promo code Bilborough in the
payment section you'll start with three
free rides up to $10 each that's up to a
$30 value
that's promo code bill burr once again
enter promo code bill burr I always stop
this [ __ ] thing press home to unlock
Jesus Christ alright yeah I got two more
here
oh here we go but oh boo boo me undies
me undies why did you vote for Trump but
dude dude do me undies me undies America
is taking a dump what were you supposed
to [ __ ] do they got rid of Bernie and
they have that [ __ ] [ __ ] alright
picture a world we're putting it on a
new pair of underwear isn't just fresh
you're stepping into a better day think
of what think about it underwear it's
the first thing you put on the last
thing and take off unless you're Matthew
McConaughey why would you settle for
anything less than the best feeling
underwear on the planet the undies
focuses solely on the on producing the
most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced your balls will thank you
your [ __ ] will also thank you no it
wasn't bad my friends at me undies sent
me a pair a few uh
a few pairs a while back and now I can't
imagine wearing anything else evidently
it really makes each day that much
better
for the price of two cocktails me undies
will deliver your favorite new pair of
underwear right to your [ __ ] doorstep
better better de guarantee you try them
on if they're not the most comfortable
underwear you know do a couple of
scissor kicks yeah you're nuts feel if
they're not the best feeling undies you
ever had they'll refund you and let you
keep your first pair for free included
in the price is the sweet touch of modal
Modell a special fabric made of the
best-in-class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times
softer than cotton now they've been
saying that for a year and the cotton
people have not said [ __ ] so I'm
believing that's true these uber cozy
undies are sold exclusively on the
undies website where you'll enjoy free
shipping in the US and Canada the rest
of you can go [ __ ] yourselves
and for a limited time everyone in my
audience gets 20% off their first order
but you have to go to our special URL my
undies dot-com / / with me undies that
with the me undies better day guarantee
you have nothing to lose so don't wait
any longer
go to my undies calm / burn right now
for 20% off your first order that's
beyond ease calm / burn and lastly but
not leastly simply fave
ever find yourself almost all the way to
work or maybe you're out with your
family and friends and you get that
nagging feeling why did I marry this
woman no not that nagging feeling you
start thinking did I close that window
did I lock the door you just don't know
it could drive you nuts
well you don't have to worry about that
anymore when you got simply safe home
security
you don't buy any nice [ __ ] you know she
wouldn't care either but that's a
different story it's a nice extra layer
of protection to know simply safe is
there simply safe has an arsenal of
senses to protect your entire home and
keep your family safe simply safe got
rid of everything that makes home
security such a pain there's no
long-term contracts no hidden fees they
won't gouge you it's $14.99 a month
that's three times less than what other
companies judge and here's some big news
simply safe just released its brand-new
high-definition security camera the
camera is different this camera is
different it connects to your security
system and sends your smartphone a video
the second something happens at home hey
honey look at that guy stealing all our
[ __ ] you can see the stubble on the side
of his face this this HD is incredible
you can see everything that's going on
so you won't have to wonder anymore call
to action okay
check out simply safes new camera today
just go to simply save bird calm right
now that simply saved bird calm hi
simply safe bird calm alright that's it
now I got once again I got to hit the
home button I got to do the whole
password [ __ ] thing
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr is
the Monday morning podcast and it's late
in the day and I finally got to it and
this is my fourth attempt there trying
to do a good one get a good one over
that line what movie set from Fast Times
at Ridgemont High mr. hand you remember
him you know the guy who played that he
was in my favorite Martian and he took
that gig back in the early 60s and for
like 30 [ __ ] years every time
somebody ran up to him they they said
hey it's that [ __ ] Martian guy and he
hated life and he hated that [ __ ]
show and then he did that show movies
Fast Times at Ridgemont High and one day
the clouds parted and some young kid
came walking up to him said hey mister
hand and evidently he was really excited
isn't that a nice showbusiness story I
don't know what the [ __ ] that has to do
with my podcast or this [ __ ] bus that
is in front of me that is not moving go
you're a bus there you go merge you [ __ ]
anyways if you new to my page or my
website I do one of these every single
week and people send me questions and I
try to answer them to the best of my
ability I try not to say [ __ ] during the
podcast but occasionally it slips out
when there's a brought us driving two
miles an hour what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me I can't say words lately I was
working at Zanies in Nashville and I
kept stumbling over words and then I
started thinking why I keep stumbling
over these words and then I almost
started stuttering on stage and speaking
of which if you came out to see me at
Zanies in Nashville Tennessee I just
want to say thank you very much and even
though I just said thank you very much
you might have sensed a little bit of
anger underneath that and it has nothing
to do with you guys it has to do with
the fact that there aren't enough hours
in the day today and I'm [ __ ]
frustrated and I basically only have
about 10 15 minutes to do this podcast
and you know usually usually I go on for
about 45 minutes but today or whatever
half hour this is going to be like an EP
kind of like
Guns N'Roses that lies album except I'm
not going to drop the n-word you know so
/ if you're listening to this if you're
one of the 14 people who listens to my
podcast you're not going to feel awkward
or after have to [ __ ] explain
yourself I don't [ __ ] know people you
know what you know what I got nothing i
got nothing this week I got nothing
funny to say I am [ __ ] burnt out I
just did back-to-back weeks on the road
plus a college you want to hear you want
to hear my my week I was in I was in
Washington DC then I was in LA and then
I went to Colorado then I flew to
Indianapolis did the Bob and Tom show
and I had a night off the night before
and because my brain never shuts off I'm
like well why the [ __ ] would I just
chill out in Indianapolis when I can
drive for [ __ ] hours up to Detroit
and go to a Red Wings game and that's
what I did except I thought it was only
a two-hour drive and it turned out it
was a [ __ ] four-hour drive four and a
half actually and I went out there was
Red Wings Penguins which turned out to
be one of the games of the year but I
had to leave before the third period
ended and I missed the Penguins come
back and went in overtime but I still
got to go to that arena and I couldn't
believe how small it was you know there
was no upper deck it just kind of went
straight up you know it was kind of an I
don't know an old school building in
like a 1975 kind of way but I was really
cool and the fans were awesome and you
know I don't like going to that
expansion [ __ ] and I don't like fair
with the fans and that Detroit's got
good fans and there were a lot of
Pittsburgh Penguin fans there talking a
lot of [ __ ] even when they were down for
two after two periods and I missed them
all talking [ __ ] when they came back and
won 7-6 and [ __ ] overtime and where
was I
driving by a [ __ ] cornfield in the
middle of Indiana by then so my brain
right now is frazzled and you know you
might wonder a row what the [ __ ] is
wrong with Bill and you know I don't
have any answers drive
hybrid I just drank three quarters of a
Sam Adams beer one of their seasonal
brews and I'm on my way to a writers
meeting because I have to go write some
sketches for something that I'm shooting
and I'm exhausted this is one of these
times when I just want to sleep for
[ __ ] 9 10 hours and wake up the next
day and just stare at the [ __ ] wall
but I can't because I have to do this I
have to somehow put my voice into a
sketch which is not an easy thing to do
I find it's very hard for me to write
sketches because I write very setup
punch set up punch there's not a lot of
layers that's not a left model left
turns you know it's just like my act
there's a lot of screaming and the
f-word
so we have to figure out how to do that
and we're at a red light so I think it's
time for a podcast question look at this
this is just like the Cash Cab okay no
question we're number one have you ever
been asked to write material for another
comedian first of all look at this
[ __ ] guy riding down the street with
a bicycle I think one that people do
that they put a reflector on their back
and then all of a sudden they just they
feel like they're like it's sort of like
a motorcycle on some level they start
riding with traffic like their Kevin
Bacon and Quicksilver you know nothing
makes me want to lean over and open my
passenger door and commit vehicular
manslaughter like some [ __ ] turn your
life somebody another like some like
that dude you know what I don't what the
[ __ ] was I told what was the question
have I ever been asked to write material
for another comedian yes yes I have I've
written for I wrote for one roast is
Shaquille O'Neal roast and I got to
admit you know at first I started
writing the jokes and I was like I don't
want to write jokes for another comedian
I want to write them for me and I want
to be able to say them so I get to laugh
but then I realized what's cool about a
roast is you're not at work like writing
for a comedians act whether than going
to go on HBO and kill with some joke and
get credit for it it's it's a very
specific
thing it's not like I have a chunk of
material about Shaquille O'Neal so what
do I care and I wrote it and evidently
it went really well people in the
writers were on my guests liked it and I
got a real kick out of it and I got one
joke on the air and I believe the joke
was something about watching Shaquille
O'Neal play basketball was like watching
a [ __ ] [ __ ] something along those
lines something along those lines of
that he was just such a big dude yeah
such a big [ __ ] dude that even when
he dunks the ball it doesn't look good
he looks like a fat kid Duncan a ball in
like a nerf hoop set and that was
basically that was basically it
I want the cheap route I use [ __ ] as a
reference you know so I'm not proud of
it but I got on the air all right here's
another one do you agree that the reason
many TV shows are abruptly canceled the
reason many TV shows are abruptly
canceled is due to the media's attempt
to control what we watch such as reality
TV okay
the media's attempt as if the entire
media is working together if you're in
the conspiracy theory I would work a
little higher up the ladder and try to
see who owns media in this country and
you'd be surprised it's not that many
people so i don't know i don't think
reality TV is an attempt to for them to
control what we watch i just think it's
really cheap and it's uh is something
mesmerizing about watching 10 losers in
a house talk [ __ ] about each other as
much as i make fun of it did that guy
just [ __ ] bump into me what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you you [ __ ] idiot
that guy's just [ __ ] rear-ended me
hang on a second
[ __ ] dude there's no [ __ ] way he
just did that
I swear to God I think some guy just
literally tap my bumper
hang on a second you know this would be
great if we get to a [ __ ] red light
cuz I know we didn't hit it hard enough
hold on hold on a second did you bump
into me hang on sir
did you just bump into me you didn't
okay I don't know it was my car or not
I wonder why you had such a nonchalant
look on your face I'm like this please
didn't alright I'm just making sure all
right sorry about this okay I uh huh
okay so anyways I mean I didn't bump
into me I think my car just had like a
hiccup but it literally felt like
somebody just tapped my [ __ ] and I
looked in the rearview mirror this guy
was right on my [ __ ] ass you guys
almost hurt in LA moment what if I
fought him I want to fight [ __ ] after
I have enough speakerphone dude then
they could have used my podcast in court
then I finally would have got class like
15 [ __ ] listeners god damnit so was
that was a moment right there that was a
moment that almost happened this stupid
question who did you just open to me uh
no I didn't oh okay Jesus can you
believe I'm not a private investigator
with that some sort of [ __ ] police
work alright so anyways anyway I gotta
wrap this podcast up cuz I'm out where
the [ __ ] I'm at so this goddamn writers
thing that I'm doing but you had a Mitch
you know that was pretty exciting that
for a second alright let's let's try
upload some of these more some more of
these questions before I get the phone
thanks everybody who came out to see me
at Zanies in Nashville Tennessee I had
an awesome time and literally tons more
people showed up since the last time
which really made me feel good that you
know people actually saw my special they
liked it and it made him want to come
out and I'm really psyched about that
and I know I've been telling you guys
I'm putting the dates up for 2009
they're definitely getting up this week
I talked to my Booker and there's
supposed to be an emailing me something
so I'll get the dates up up on
website up on my myspace page please
come out to see me and you'll watch me
put together my next special that
hopefully I will tape this summer coming
summer so anyways there's a long
question about corporate America hey
Bill let me tell you why I effin hate
corporate America especially Verizon
exclamation point they sold me a
blackberry that recently for the fifth
time the keyboard wouldn't work couldn't
make our answer calls and couldn't do
anything each time what would happen I
go to Verizon they would fix it for me
but the last time a few weeks ago a
buddy of mine in the Army was called the
day before he shipped off to Iraq and I
was unable to answer the call Jesus that
sounds like a Lifetime movie I can't
answer the phone I need to say goodbye
so I went to Verizon furiously as you
should have demanding an explanation on
why they sold me such a shitty phone
they told me that they could do was
replace it with the same model phone in
which my response was all you'd be doing
is giving me a shiny or piece of [ __ ]
god bless you god bless you that's
exactly what you should have said and
then you should have taken the phone and
bury the side of his head and blamed him
for that design as if he designed it
alright
leading me and this basically led him to
sign up with AT&T and now Verizon wants
to charge me with $125 early termination
fee I've been arguing my case with them
on the phone trying to explain to them
that if I still had Verizon I wouldn't
be able to make this phone call they
kept telling me that they understand why
I'm except upset which my response was
great so if you understand why you still
asked for my money and basically there
is no way that I'm going to buckle and
give it into them good good for you I
keep calling them disputing them I'll
keep calling them disputing up for two
years if I have to to me it's a matter
of principle
because what pisses me off is how these
corporations are allowed to conduct
business you know I don't need the rest
read the rest is exactly exactly fit
bigger than you and they have more money
than you and they can wait you out and
then they can send you [ __ ] to a
collection agency because you're the
little guy and they know that you're not
going to do that this is what you want
to do you
you got to do that old-school thing just
go I want to speak to a manager and you
keep going up the ladder we're asking to
speak to somebody about them get
everybody's name keep using words like
ridiculous and outrageous like this is
ridiculous this is outrageous and just
do it the way like an old lady would and
just just don't get off the phone don't
ever curse if you never curse then they
can't they can't hang up on you I'm full
of [ __ ] I don't know what to do you know
what go burn down their [ __ ] building
or something but I'm sorry man I really
didn't answer that question well but I
got to go in and do this meeting so
whatever thanks for listening to the
Monday morning podcast I know this was
real short but hey we had a nice yelling
match with a potential yelling match
with another person in a car which
turned out to be friendly how bad did
you guys want that to escalate into
violence you know you did and you could
have heard me get my ass kicked
now that I just roll down the window
like I've ever taken a karate class it
was [ __ ] ridiculous but fortunately
[ __ ] didn't go down that way so anyways
it was very short very exciting TJ
Hooker episode of the Monday morning
podcast keep listening please keep
sending the questions and that is it god
bless all yeah please come and see me at
Caroline's in New York City the first
week in December and that is it and I
apologize to the guy who I thought hit
my car but really didn't if he's a
podcast listener all right dude that's
it
all right guys take it easy take it easy
bye guys take it easy bye guys take it
easy